are you single or not Rihanna that's
tough because I couldn't speak that one
too there's a bead maybe this is Joe
Ellen B Fox that's probably Kevin Durant
indeed I'm watching The History Channel
in the club and I'm wondering how do
these people know what's going on on The
Sun Ain't nobody ever been this is a
smart thought who the heck is this you
would say something like that I don't
know maybe Kevin Durant what's it Joe
Allen beat again I think this is Katie
Katie the weird ones you know I mean I
don't know I don't know I just felt like
that was a KD tweet Scarlett Johansson I
would drink your bath water once yeah
this is a tough one Kevin Durant this is
Kevin Durant Kevin Durant yes that makes
sense I just tasted the first time a
smoothie man God Bless America I have no
clue since the grammar's a little off I
don't know Lucas be honest this was Jana
God Bless America gave it away